so now when you're up and running with
conference central you have a pretty
good idea of how to write and deploy App
Engine applications in the last lesson
we also covered usage management and we
added it to conference central so only
authenticated users can access the
application when you write applications
you very often need to store data and as
you know there are a number of ways you
can do this App Engine is no exception
it can work with a number of different
storage technologies but there is one
that is particularly important it's
called datastore
this is the big table restaurants here
at Google you may have heard a big table
it's a technology Google created and
published a famous paper about in 2006
BigTable allows unlimited amount of data
to be stored and searched effectively
and many of the huge services being run
here at Google
choose BigTable to store data you know
what App Engine datastore also uses
BigTable that means that your
applications get the same massive scale
isn't that great hmm but I'm starting to
feel a little bit hungry hey I think
I'll go in and get a big bite in the
BigTable restaurant see you in class